[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y esto
es aquí América este es el programa de
France 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que vamos a ver
hoy el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro y el de El Salvador nayib bukele
se engancharon en una discusión en
Twitter luego de que el mandatario
colombiano comparara con un campo de
concentración las imágenes difundidas
por el salvadoreño de supuestos
pandilleros en su mega cárcel de máxima
seguridad
y Venezuela cumple 10 años sin Hugo
Chávez lo amen o lo odian se trata de un
personaje que pasó a la historia y
transformó profundamente no solo a su
país sino a toda América la corresponsal
de France 24 en Caracas nos cuenta en
qué quedó su proyecto socialista
y vamos de inmediato a El Salvador para
revisar la imagen de la semana el
gobierno de nayib bukele comenzó el
traslado de los primeros privados de la
libertad a su prisión de máxima
seguridad y difundió estas imágenes de
los presuntos pandilleros sin camiseta
esposados y amontonados son personas que
han sido detenidas bajo el régimen de
estado de excepción una medida que
limita los derechos constitucionales y
que fue implementada por bukele en marzo
de 2022 bajo el argumento de disminuir
la tasa de homicidios en el país
centroamericano que era una de las más
altas del mundo para un país que no está
en guerra
en 2015 esta tasa llegó a ser de 103
asesinatos por cada 100.000 habitantes
pero desde entonces tiene una tendencia
a la baja de acuerdo con cifras
oficiales bukele llegó al poder en 2019
cuando El Salvador tenía una tasa de 36
homicidios por cada 100.000 habitantes
el país cerró 2022 con una tasa de 7.8
bukele asegura que esta disminución se
debe a su lucha contra las pandillas ha
arrestado a más de 60.000 personas bajo
el estado de excepción que asegura son
mareros o pandilleros sin embargo
familiares de estas personas privadas de
la libertad han denunciado que algunos
no tienen vínculos con las maras en
France 24 hablamos con una de ellas
quien nos pidió proteger su identidad y
nos contó que su padre un sencillo
campesino de 67 años Fue detenido
arbitrariamente
tiene más de 45 años de trabajar en una
finca café
frijol y ahí lo crecimos todos en esa
finca en estos Huracanes cosechando
mis hermanos
iba mi papá mi hermano mayor mi sobrino
el lleno de mi hermano y mi cuñado y un
niño de nueve años
la mamá era el sustento de él económico
mi hermano mi hermana y este pues ella
se dedicaban a trabajar ese día cuando
fueron suspendidos algunas cuencas
siendo una persona muy inocentes solo
porque pobres
porque son mis hermanos mis sobrinas mis
cuñados
también
limpios con antecedentes
policialmente y este lo único que les
pusieron en educación ilícita y si no
los han soltado ahorita porque no tiene
ninguna prueba como para para demostrar
que
haciendo cosas intelectivas además
hablamos con Ingrid Escobar ella es
directora administrativa del Socorro
jurídico humanitario en El Salvador
quien representa a familiares de
personas privadas de la libertad y nos
expuso las pruebas que tienen sobre
estas detenciones arbitrarias
las pruebas que tenemos pues son
suficientes verdad nosotros
Este es un este son casos de crímenes de
lesa humanidad y que se deben de ver
bueno las muertes de doscientas personas
dentro de centros penales espacios de
investigación inocentes ninguna con
tatuajes nosotros tenemos exactamente
todas las pruebas que nunca han estado
presos antes que tienen una vida
familiar normal tenemos los documentos
que lo prueban arreglos domiciliares
etcétera entonces ahí hay suficientes
pruebas suficiente para comprobar que
estas personas se trataban de personas
civiles verdad y este es un ataque
sistematizado en contra de estos grupos
de personas inocentes por lo tanto se
configura claramente en crímenes
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos recibieron más de siete
mil novecientas denuncias de violaciones
la mayoría de detenciones arbitrarias
durante el año en el que ha estado
vigente el estado de excepción el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro se
unió a las críticas y comparó las
imágenes difundidas por el gobierno
salvadoreño con un campo de
concentración
el campo de concentración del Salvador
lleno de jóvenes miles y miles
encarcelados
que le haga uno escalofríos yo creo que
hay gente que le gusta eso
indudablemente
ver a la juventud de entre las cárceles
y creen que eso es la seguridad
y se disparan las popularidades
indudablemente lo vivimos también en
Colombia presidente del Salvador se
siente orgulloso porque redujo la tasa
de homicidios a partir dice él de un
sometimiento de las bandas que hoy andan
en esas cárceles En mi opinión dantescas
el presidente de El Salvador le
respondió y ambos se engancharon en un
intercambio de tuits en el que el que
también es conocido como el presidente
milenial criticó que Petro se atribuyera
logros de administraciones previas esto
fue lo que le dijo
señor Gustavo Petro los resultados pesan
más que La retórica deseo que Colombia
en realidad logre bajar los índices de
homicidios como lo hemos logrado los
salvadoreños Dios los bendiga
no es La retórica son los hechos las
detenciones arbitrarias una flagrante
violación al artículo siete de la
convención americana que establece que
nadie puede ser sometido a detención o
encarcelamiento arbitrarios esta misma
convención americana de la que se ha
hablado mucho para denunciar prácticas
antidemocráticas en Venezuela o Perú
Establece en su Artículo 5 además que
toda persona Privada de la libertad está
bajo responsabilidad del Estado ha
perdido su autonomía por lo que el
estado es el que debe velar porque las
condiciones de su detención sean dignas
y garanticen sus derechos humanos no
porque sean criminales o no sino por su
simple condición de humanos
y cambiamos de tema y nos vamos a
Venezuela el 5 de marzo de 2013 falleció
el presidente Hugo Chávez a los 58 años
tras dos años de lucha contra el cáncer
que así anunciaba
confirmaron la existencia de un tumor
abscesado
con presencia de células cancerígenas
lo cual hizo necesaria la realización de
una segunda intervención quirúrgica que
permitió la extracción total de dicho
tumor
Chávez llegó al poder tras ganar las
elecciones de 1998 y tras un fallido
golpe de estado en 1992 estuvo casi 15
años en el poder tras modificar la
Constitución para permitir su reelección
a través de un referendo durante su
mandato sacó a millones de personas de
la pobreza gracias a los programas
sociales utilizando las ganancias
petroleras pero espanto a los
inversionistas a través de
expropiaciones y estrictos controles de
cambio antes de morir Le entregó la
batuta a Nicolás Maduro un ex conductor
de autobús que había nombrado como su
canciller pero que no cuenta con el
carisma ni la capacidad oratoria de
Chávez y quien se ha mantenido en el
poder a través de su legado haciendo
malabares para gobernar un país en
crisis y con un eventual reto de
elección presidencial en 2024 en este
escenario
que obligaría a convocar como manda la
Constitución de nuevo a elecciones
presidenciales
ustedes elijan a Nicolás Maduro como
presidente de la República bolivariana
de Venezuela yo se los pido desde mi
corazón
un líder carismático con una retórica
anti estadounidense y antiimperialista
que ya sea que lo ame No lo odia en
cambio a Venezuela y América Bajo su
liderazgo los presidentes desde Cuba
hasta argentina se unieron en la época
dorada de la izquierda latinoamericana
por favor no hagamos diálogo han tenido
tiempo para plantear su posición
presidente termine y después presidente
Hugo Chávez podrá ser español
ayer estuvo el aquí
en este mismo lugar huele a azufre
todavía
esta mesa
donde me ha tocado hablar el cuerpo de
Chávez permanece en el museo de la
revolución de Caracas y 10 años después
su proyecto socialista no logró
consolidarse en medio de la crisis
económica muchos de sus seguidores ya no
son tan leales el informe es de nuestra
corresponsal en Caracas Daniela Zambrano
Carlos castañas es uno de los tantos
chavistas que hoy se siente decepcionado
el gobierno revolucionario al que tanto
apoyó lo desalojó de la propiedad que
cuidaba desde hace 25 años tras el
fallecimiento de sus sueños ahora vive
en una habitación en precarias
condiciones
reventaron al candado de mi casa y
entonces me sacaron de ahí engañado
diciéndome que me iba a que me iba a dar
una casita que me iban a dar aunque sea
un kiosquito y no me lo dieron
además de estar sin una vivienda digna
Carlos tampoco cuenta con recursos para
adquirirlas esta básica como el 81% de
la población su pensión apenas alcanza
los 7 dólares
hago una sola comidita y mira yo antes
estaba así Ahora Mira cómo estoy
en el oeste de Caracas Gregorio
Velázquez Vocero del Consejo comunal de
la parroquia de Santa Rosalía se encarga
de organizar a los habitantes del barrio
para resolver sus necesidades hoy
también está a cargo de promover la
movilización para homenajear Hugo Chávez
de la montaña el domingo para conmemorar
la fecha que se fue nuestro comandante
aunque aún es un chavista orgulloso está
consciente de que el país a través de
una crisis económica que afecta a todos
por igual sabe que ha habido fallas pero
aún así no culpa al gobierno ni a la
revolución bolivariana han habido pactos
entre factores de internos de nuestro
país opositores Generalmente con el
Imperio gringo que es quien genera las
sanciones a diez años el fallecimiento
de Hugo Chávez su proyecto socialista no
logró erigirse como fue concebido para
este analista político Nicolás Maduro
está creando un nuevo modelo distinto al
de 1999 donde se contemplan los valores
del capitalismo para conectar con otros
sectores de la sociedad ha cambiado el
panorama económico ya se habla de dólar
claramente ya no se habla tanto del
Bolívar soberano como tal la moneda
nacional ahora se habla incluso de este
banca digital o criptomonedas eso era
impensable en la época de Chávez por
otro lado desde el punto de vista social
ya descuidaron el chavismo descuido todo
lo que tiene que ver colectivos bases de
emisiones cada cinco de marzo se le
rinde homenaje al fallecido presidente y
algunos de sus más cercanos aliados ya
no conmemoran con el gobierno porque no
forman parte del círculo de poder para
la victoria siempre hermano en seremos
seguidores como Gregorio intentan
mantener su legado vivo pero la
corrupción y las promesas incumplidas
han llevado a la decepción a muchos como
Carlos que esperaban más del proyecto
socialista
y me despido desde chile con el
descubrimiento de un nuevo moai una de
las características estatuas de la isla
de Pascua que constituyen el principal
atractivo turístico de ese lugar el
hallazgo se realizó en febrero en el
centro de una laguna que comenzó a
secarse en 2018 según expertos la
estructura de 1,60 metros puede abrir
una nueva perspectiva de la historia de
la isla y de sus antepasados gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
América en la producción estuvo Luis
Fernando Montes y Natalie Quiroga en la
producción de invitados Sigan viendo
France 24
[Música]